[Music]
u.s
intelligence agencies are still trying
to stop the most sophisticated
cyber security breach in american
history nearly a year
after it began experts believe russia
was behind the hack of a company called
solar winds sending malware to 18
000 private and government organizations
include including the u.s departments of
justice
treasury state and homeland security
russia has denied any involvement in the
hack former hacker john miller
now a cyber security expert told 60
minutes
the scope of the attack was impressive
i would never do something like this it
creates too much damage
miller says with the solar winds attack
russia has demonstrated
that none of the software we take for
granted is truly safe
including the apps on our telephones
laptops and tablets
these days he says any device can be
sabotaged
when you buy something from a tech
company a new phone or a laptop
you trust that that is secure when they
give it to you
and what they've shown us in this attack
is that is not the case
they have the ability to compromise
those supply chains and manipulate
whatever they want
whether it's financial data source code
the functionality of these products
they can take control so for instance
they could destroy
all the computers on a network oh easily
the malware that they
deployed off of solarwinds it didn't
have the functionality in it to do that
but to do that is trivial
chris krebs was director of the
department of homeland security's
cyber security and infrastructure
security agency also called sisa
until last november he is now a partner
at krebs stamos group
which was hired by solarwinds to help
investigate the hack
he joins us now good morning chris thank
you for being with us
this attack has been going on for nearly
a year as we mentioned it's still going
on
what is your biggest concern about what
russia is doing
well good morning anthony thanks for
having me on to john miller's point
this was an attack on the very trust
that enables the current digital
ecosystem and when you think about how
businesses how government agencies are
building their networks they're shifting
to the cloud to cloud computing to
services that are managed by third
parties and those relationships
are rooted in trust and the russian
intelligence service the svr
compromised that trust and to me that's
what's so
uh reckless and damaging about this
specific campaign
was the the brazen attack on trust and
we have to rebuild and regain that trust
throughout our networks in the u.s and
elsewhere if i mean the words john
miller's words that were really haunting
uh and and i'm wondering about the
implications of this for ordinary folks
because he's suggesting that that
anybody at home could be vulnerable here
how how concerned should folks at home
be about their own personal data in all
this
so i think this specific campaign by the
russian intelligence service
was an exquisite operation
really focused on gathering intelligence
from the government and from
key businesses i think you know your
viewers
have a different set of threats they
need to be concerned about and that is
from
cyber criminals that would seek to steal
their
financial information you know get into
their bank accounts and things like that
but this specific
campaign is much more focused on
gathering intelligence from the federal
government
it was a private company that discovered
this hack
when it got to government agencies why
didn't cesa
see it yeah so it was detected by one of
the premier
cyber security companies in the world
that they had
is also been compromised in terms of
cis's capabilities the program last
night discussed
einstein and einstein is really a
fundamental security program
for the federal government that is
designed to detect
known threats this was not a known
threat this was a novel
technique a novel path never seen before
and so einstein was not configured for
that there are a separate set of
technologies that are in the process of
deployment
right now by the federal government that
will put us in a position
to detect these sorts of attacks going
forward
in what i understand the administration
is doing the the white house national
security council led by
the new deputy national security adviser
anne newberger
they are contemplating a wide-ranging
executive order
that will accelerate the security
programs the
investment congress does need to ramp up
investment
in security efforts but we'll really
look to
as i mentioned earlier regain trust
understand those third party those
private sector companies that software
provides software and services
and make sure that we understand the
risk that's involved
uh with those programs and and really
lock down uh
agency networks and quickly a former nsa
deputy director told 60 minutes the only
way to end this attack
is to get rid of all the affected
networks and hardware is that what it's
going to take
and how quickly can they do that
so chris inglis is a friend i know him
well i think that probably the more cost
effective approach is to assume that
even prior to this
uh campaign that the russians were
already there and the russians will be
there in the future
and so what you need to do is you hunt
relentlessly across
those agency networks and that's what
cis has been empowered to do by congress
now congress needs to follow up with the
funding all right chris krebs thank you
so much for being with us this morning
we appreciate it